at the start of the movie we see a bunch
of inmates at a maximum level
Penitentiary trying to make their way
out through a tunnel that they have dug
the plan unfortunately fails so they
revert to something more dangerous the
inmates Gather in the open field face
the giant wall next to them and run at
it at full speed the plan is to strike
the wall at once and break it into
pieces following this the movie flashes
back to a few months earlier we are
introduced to the protagonist a
notorious and fearless gangster named
Chi sung Who works for a wealthy
billionaire named Kim he is Infamous for
beating up threatening and even killing
people if required one day Chi sung is
ordered to take out a scientist named
Choi so he heads there along with his
gang the old man begs for his life and
even offers the gang a lot of cash but
every single one of them refuses when
she sung gets bored he lunges towards
Choi with a knife and the screen Fades
to Black in the next scene we get to
know that the gangsters were
surprisingly apprehended by the cough as
for the old man he has survived the
assassination attempt with only minor
injuries a prosecutor Corners Chi sung
and forces him to reveal the name of the
organization he works for he even
promises to reduce his sentence to just
two years in exchange for the invaluable
information however she sung refuses to
open his mouth he would rather die than
rat his boss out at last the case goes
to a hearing and she sung is sentenced
to eight years in a maximum level prison
while his boss Kim is proud of his
loyalty he is also nervous that someday
Chi sung might open his mouth later when
she sung as being escorted to his cell
he hears someone whistling and
immediately recognizes it in the blink
of an eye he fights off the guards
breaks free from them and rushes to the
place where the sound is coming from Chi
sung as shocked and delighted when he
sees that his best friend and old
associate sun tan is still alive
sometimes I think soon tan is still
alive too but then I just burn it turns
out the latter had been sentenced to a
death penalty few years ago for
murdering someone later the two catch up
in the playground and reminisce about
their childhood soon tan also inquires
about his family and when he learns that
his parents have passed away he becomes
dejected nonetheless he is hopeful that
someday he will get out of this desolate
place during the lunch break she sung
meets several other prisoners who have
heard stories of his bravery and loyalty
they promise to help him with anything
he wants in the prison but the group's
conversation is cut short when the local
bully gang arrives there and warns the
newbies to keep quiet she sung stairs at
the leader for a while but he doesn't
react at the moment elsewhere Kim goes
to meet Choi at the hospital and
proposes that they do business together
the latter is unaware that he was almost
assassinated by the same person sitting
next to him so he agrees to the deal he
has one catch though since he was
humiliated by Chi sung earlier he wants
him dead so Choi asks Kim to kill the
notorious gangster by the end of the
week hearing this Kim is caught in a
serious Dilemma on one hand Chi sung as
his trusted account plus and on the
other hand he wants to seal the deal at
any cost after a bit of deliberation he
eventually goes with the second option
and agrees to assassinate his own
right-hand man later he visits she sung
in the prison and falsely assures him
that he is doing everything he can to
secure his release our protagonist
quickly buys into the deceit and becomes
happy that his boss cares for him he
then reveals that soon tan is alive and
dwell in the prison for certain reasons
this doesn't make Kim happy indicating
that the two had some sort of beef in
the past in the meantime we are
introduced to another one of chi Sung's
close friends and fellow gang members
Joo Jung he visits Chi Sung's home and
informs his parents about the recent
developments surprisingly the old couple
are not surprised at all since their son
was always a notorious criminal as the
three continued chatting we are shown an
old picture on the wall which reveals
that jujung Chi sung and sun tan have
been best friends since childhood they
grew up together and became gang members
together back in the prison once all the
guards are away Chi sung Summits reveal
a secret tunnel they've been digging for
months they are actually planning a
prison break Chi sung is both impressed
and tempted by their plan but he knows
that a small mistake can lead to dire
consequences in another cell the group
of bullies violently Attacks An Innocent
inmate named Moon Su the following
morning at breakfast she sung sees Moon
Sue's bruised and tear-streaked face and
feels a Pang of sympathy unable to
withstand the Injustice anymore he
surprisingly retaliates against the
bullies by delivering a severe beating
on them all the other inmates can only
watch in awe as a single man takes down
an entire gang that she Sung's actions
are in him a lot of respect they also
land him in solitary confinement
elsewhere the scientist Choi takes Kim
to his Factory and reveals that he's
extracting a deadly serum from a rare
Japanese plant this serum can kill
people in an instant without any pain or
discomfort Choi offers to sell the serum
to Kim but with one crucial condition
she sung has to be killed first that
night a group of of men violently invade
Chi Sung's parents home brutally beat
them and run away in the morning one of
Kim's henchmen approaches the bullied
inmate Moon Sue and offers him money to
kill Chi sung however Moon Sue feels a
sense of indebtedness towards Chi sung
and is torn between his loyalty and the
temptation of Quick Cash elsewhere Kim's
rival gangster bong Sheik pays him a
visit that's a that's a sick name it is
revealed that he has become handicapped
after Chi sung stabbed him in the legs
seven times so now he's seeking Revenge
as the First Act of retaliation he sent
his men over to Chi Sung's house and
brutally attacked his parents last night
jujung who is also there hears about
this and immediately rushes to the old
couple fortunately they are still
breathing so jujung takes them to the
hospital for medical attention the
following day Chi Sung's girlfriend
visits him in the prison and reveals
that his parents have been attacked the
devastating news engulfs Chi sung in a
whirlwind of emotions but little did he
know that more trouble is about to come
his way that evening as he is slowly
walking towards his cell Moon Sue
suddenly appears from behind and stabs
him however instead of fighting back she
sung remains calm and tells him to run
away it appears as if he is slowly going
to pass away but in the nick of time
some guards find him and Rush him to the
hospital in the meantime jujung learns
about the attack and also gets to know
that his boss was behind it enraged he
tries confronting Kim but his friends
stop him saying it's a bad idea
following this jujung makes his way to
the hospital to visit Chi sung Who has
regained Consciousness and is recovering
well as they catch up chi-sung is
informed about his boss's heinous plan
to have him killed although he is
disappointed by the Revelation he is not
entirely surprised as he has always
known that Kim would betray anyone for
his own benefits later jujung returns to
work and tells his boss that she sung is
still unconscious hoping to buy more
time and keep his friends safe from
further harm in the next scene she sung
makes a triumphant return to the prison
and his fellow inmates celebrate his
survival but rather than resign himself
to a life Behind Bars he begins to plan
a daring escape with his cellmates they
communicate with their Associates on the
outside in code language and carefully
plot their escape one night they execute
their plan and crawl through the vents
making their way towards the sewer
system but as they reach a fork in the
tunnel they are faced with a difficult
Decision One path leads to an army base
while the other leads to an airway base
unsure which path to take they decide to
return to their cell and regroup the
following morning the group starts
digging an underground tunnel hoping to
find the correct path to the airway base
they work tirelessly for weeks putting
in all their efforts in sweat but one
day the prison Warden announces that
everyone is being shifted to the second
floor after their tunnel plan falls
through Chi sung and his group come up
with a new plan to escape the prison by
destroying the old surrounding wall they
attempt to push it down every day during
their break time but only end up hurting
themselves the guards watch this from
their towers but only make fun of them
knowing that their efforts are futile
however one day a unbeknownst to all of
them the wall finally starts cracking
meanwhile jujung and his fellow gang
members are in the countryside playing
with their new weapons when jujung fires
a shot in the air it accidentally hits a
plane flying overhead causing it to
spiral out of control out of all the
places it crashes right outside of the
prison as the wall breaks from the
impact she sung and his friends make a
run for it and many other inmates follow
suit resulting in chaos inside the
prison over half of the prisoners
managed to escape including Chi sung and
his four friends in no time the news of
the prison break becomes National
headlines and Kim's gang also learns of
it making him nervous meanwhile she sung
in his group hide inside a photo studio
and take the owner hostage so as to
evade the police they also managed to
steal clothes from a nearby dry cleaner
and change into them to avoid being
recognized as they watch the news they
learn that one of their gang members who
was caught by the police has revealed
their gang's name as love and friendship
hell yeah translated to English that's
the worst gang name of all time despite
their dire situation the group is taken
aback by this name and can't help but to
laugh at it oh okay it's bad regardless
while in hiding the hostage woman is
forced to cook for them and surprisingly
she does it willingly and with care as
if they were her house guests soon Chi
Sung's girlfriend arrives with phones
and money for everyone she is happy to
finally be with her man but due to
safety reasons he abruptly breaks up
with her and tells her to stay away with
the police still searching for them the
group discusses their options and what
they should do next they know they
cannot hide forever and must come up
with a plan to either escape the country
or clear their names however she sung
firstly wants to take revenge against
the people who attacked his parents the
group is skeptical about the idea but
they eventually decide to join him as
the first phase of their plan they sneak
inside bong Sheik's Hideout and brutally
beat all of his men up then she sung
Corners bong Sheik in his car and stabs
his other legs several times making sure
he can never walk again and meanwhile
due to the news of the prison break Choi
finds out that she sung is still alive
and becomes enraged he confronts Kim
about the lie and decides to back out of
the deal but this only enrages the
cunning billionaire he attacks Choi
brutally calling him a good for nothing
scientist in the next scene we see that
she sung as hell bent on taking down his
former boss Kim but when he reaches The
Hideout he is stopped by his best friend
jujung who is still loyal to the
billionaire both of them ask each other
to step away but when neither of them
budge a fight ensues she sung obviously
emerges Victorious and once he is done
with his friend he and his group take
down the other gangsters amidst all this
Chi sung notices Kim trying to escape so
he follows them in a car but once again
jujung stops him this time with a gun in
his hand she sung warns his best friend
to get out of the way but when the
latter doesn't move he has no choice but
to drive at him at full speed in the
last second jujung shockingly puts his
gun away revealing that he never
intended on pulling the trigger but by
this this time it's too late as chisung
fails to stop the car in time he crashes
into his best friend and seriously
injures him riddled with guilt and
sorrow he immediately loads jujung into
the car and drives him to the hospital
meanwhile all his friends are arrested
by the cops one after the other she sung
himself as chased by several police cars
through the busy streets of Busan he has
the chance to escape via a dark tunnel
but he decides to stay on the road and
reach the hospital unfortunately the
decision turns out to be the wrong one
as the cops soon Corner him as Chi sung
comes out he notices that Kim is also at
the same Junction coincidentally in a
fit of rage he takes out a knife and
attempts to kill the billionaire but
right then a half-dead jujung gets up
and shoots Kim to death for his actions
he is shot multiple times by the cops
but at least he saved his best friend
from further trouble the screen Fades to
black as we hear Chi sung saying I'm
sorry jujung I'm sorry for everything
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching